we're going to go from this result this
result here it's one of those unassuming
things in the whole of mathematics it's
like it's like a statement it's like
what does that even like you
differentiate something you just get
back itself believe it or not we're
going to take this and use it to solve
two different things number one this is
for differentiating an exponential with
a particular base but the place i
started with moves me all kinds of
different bases can I use this to solve
this and the answer is like hands so the
first thing I'm going to do is work out
how to deal in here watches this
exponential by every single exponential
I know this thing that I put a box here
I can do it and secondly it or use it to
do laws so this is my
so here's why we're going to take this
first we're going to look at other bases
return back to this original problem
trying to sway I what's happening with
this cave is like I said it was a number
but I do nothing about it like this is
my fancy way this is mathematicians
fancy way of saying I don't actually
know it if you have this town but it's a
number like was a VX I'm going to pull
out some exponential so index and some
Loblaws on you you know them pretty well
for last year but it might take a bit of
her so here's the first thing I'm going
to say y equals 8 the power of X but
even have X is no use to me I only know
things where it's e to power it right so
what I do is turn this guy into
something with a base of e ok hmm now
this is a bit tricky we haven't done
this for quite some time ok i'm going to
show you what the answer is first and
then let's try and intact it's going on
this is how i'm going to rephrase it ok
now if you haven't been playing around
with exponential to one's for a while
you might think may I did that come
would you call you right back to what an
expedition is something like this right
means that's something it's grown tell
me how long it's growing for right
another time and i'll tell you well how
big the size is after such and such a
matter and that's what an exponential
says when you flip around and you're
going to logs remember l and it's just
your phone log base e if i say log base
e of s it's asking the same question by
the universe it says based on a certain
size of you end up at how long were you
going for ok now can you see why this
and this are the same thing right watch
this is you're going to grow for
something that time ok and then i'll
tell you how big you end up this tells
you an amount of time what amount of
time is that it's the time that you take
to grow to that size right so this is a
I'm growing it aside this means i'm
growing for such a time they'll end up
in this science so therefore the answer
that science that's just weak and done
so in a more simple form its kind of
dude this is the this is the identity
that we're taking advantage on okay but
in this particular case I don't just
have X I've got a to the X okay so
that's why I have done this are you okay
so far are you with me yeah it's giving
me through think that our back to your
Lord wars right Lord wars lord I can do
something this i can simplify this a
little bit clarify how can I simplify
this instead of hanging up excellent
power yeah very good that power can try
to front me from the coefficient right
so this is e to the X log and okay with
that go be drunk now this is well it
doesn't look like it's all that much
better but actually it's a tremendous
amount better look at this growth is
stone's throw away from me e to the X
itself so i can use the field this it's
really really good I just need to make
it a little more obvious so here's what
I'll do i'm going to introduce a
substitution because what i really have
here is a function in the power
something of another function namely X
ok ok we used to seeing function of
function like this your exit was
the parent head there is a function it's
being raised to a power function of a
function but exactly the same thing is
happening here it's just different
functions involved so if i let u equal x
log a i can use chain rule on this thing
right just like i use chain rule on
something like this in fact we're really
good at this right this is what i've
substituted for you so I'm going to say
y is equal to e to the new and then over
here I need to know for the chain rule
I'm going to need to know the derivative
of this park is right food x log air
that's my function so what's the
derivative remember what's going on a is
just a number yeah and Lord bc of a
number is I'm not then hope her right so
this is actually just a constant it's
just the constant times X like 3x or 5x
or minus ninety nine x so poor you end
up with E is log a oh by the way um i
would say lawmakers a logarithm some
people read that as then a cuz it's an
element and i had a friend named with so
don't i don't do that but whatever i'm
saying mod and I'm just kind of leave
your fam magnets basic okay now I almost
ready I've got this of rephrase that so
now i can say what the derivative is
using channel right it's going to be dy
only do you don't do yes that's just
standard channel that you've been using
for months now right okay this is y is a
function of you what happens when we
differentiate that with respect to you
by definition you just get that same
thing handed back to you just different
variables right so I've got e to view
paying upfront I just established what
this is that's all day okay the last
thing they need to do is get rid of this
new business I introduced it
artificially to try and solve the
problem right so I should really get rid
of it and tidy up Peter you are you what
do you think you either you if you have
a look at this line here or this series
of lines rather into the unit exactly
the same as a VX right it's a straight
line through there so this guy in here
is a to the X natural log of a so you
remember how I said before is some
number no but it is but that's the scale
factor well you don't need to want to
know what the scale factor is that is
the scale factor okay and of course you
don't don't wanna writing this but you
can see why it works if you're
differentiating eat in the x-ray it
still fits this is stuff it it's either
the X 18 but log base e of e is 1 so
there you go that's a special case where
you're looking at the part where this
long term catches up what's this
agreement of this is what this 100 cars
okay so i use this where did i use it i
used it right there see that
at this one I had to differentiate this
but I can't I can't do that unless I've
already established and defy it this to
be the case okay so this is what we
observed this is what I define and I use
that definition making up when i
differentiate evening because this is
not a constant is differentiating with
respect to you and you is a user
severity with my target fatburger basis